no barril sr guerra ela linda mello a
idéia de andré
aí com muita boa música em twickenham
gostar do que qualquer música do rei com
a música que você cantava sem saberem
lema cantava com certeza absoluta que
estava cantando em inglês certo como eu
estava errado mas jura de pé junto a
vocês a votar na escola no recreio
puxado na área humanas in anger ainda
nené não é qualquer um que tivesse
passional ele completar vamos com
certeza absoluta que estava cantando
certo formou em inglês mais chances de
se tornar o lar i am ozzy enxerguei
florida né não
bahgat 15 mil estava salva o dia da
escola maria leonor assim o gueto
coringa mero num a professora de inglês
chegar lá também não perder a vaga dos
alunos é porque realmente quando se
pensa na busca do rio é muito fácil
cantar em inglês por exemplo cantar uma
música do rei conquistou a cabeça vai
completar na tua casa de tão fácil que é
aquela música do nec nec nec nec xuxa
famosa e mais música dele que é muito
fácil a música só votar naqueles de cada
frase abel nec nec nec nec ensino na
fuga estão como é fácil e com a cabeça
já que completa de tão fácil assim
sofrido assim não linka cabeça
totalmente completa
me estranha ii
ciro lei é no bar e bar e no barão não
eram sim não foi o que eu falei mas a
hipocrisia e consumiu subiu caio é
milionário a vestiu se estiver deixando
na poupança para quem é e aí ela que
assistiu ao canal todos vocês
começou agora e você gostou de ter
lembrado das músicas do e clique em
gostei aqui tá eu falo sempre no começo
do vídeo não esquecer quando sai no
final então já deixou logo gostei eu tô
aqui embaixo publicando uma mãe que tem
assim você dá que eu tô o final de
semana só você fica ligado em gente eu
tô aqui pra falar a agenda do inter são
30 de agosto resende rio de janeiro 31
de agosto cachoeiro de itapemirim
espírito santo alô galera de gramado rio
grande do sul é de setembro maravilhoso
toda pensando junto 8 de setembro bento
gonçalves eu grande do sul 9 de setembro
o ingresso vai estar em canoas no rio
grande do sul
a nossa região e atenção em gent 16 de
setembro em campo grande mato grosso do
sul não vão perder em gent jô está vendo
esse filho não queria que tivesse dado
mas foi a sabrina sato falou eu não
comprei ingresso no site do meu boné o
nível do jogo caiu no chão um saco que o
clube do antigo antigo explicou então é
segundo motivo que eu falava rápido dias
falava segure nunca segurei a eliminar
seguro pra pegar no meu caso é eu
comprei um sábado em que categoria
desenvolver e nicky barmby cadex imea
eu sou governinho a busca do dragon ball
z cantava vosso presente o perigo eo
carro e ouvir e descobrir um dia disse
que não é nosso presente é posso
pressentir posso presente em lei e para
quando era criança eu tinha seguro tinha
eu queria seu governo e eu cantava vosso
presente o perigo e ioga canon votar
várias busca dos anéis em inglês no qual
é a vida inteira e se é verdade fato a
vida inteira errado atirei o pau no gato
estava atirei o pau no gato mais o gato
não morreu
recorreu do nash kakadu miro cerceou
nash kaká do mir ou cc e o dia desse
galera sentir nenhum dia desde agora já
depois de grande descobrir que é dona
chica kaká admirou sei que eu achava que
o melhor era quem era o marido da dona
chica miro está aqui quem tem muito isso
é o francisco de quem abandona cef é o
chip do gás é a faca da panificadora
facto eu achava que a dona chica era de
quem dormir o marido da dona chica
entendeu que nunca ninguém cantá
certinho mexican admirou o teté do b rua
do verão que o jogador deu 00 ao longo
de saboroso achacado chega de quem do
miro aí vocês pensaram isso não faz
sentido o dormir ou algo assim o que é
que faz sentir nessa música minha e um
pau no gato
a dona chica em vez de ajudá admirou
ccdp huck da picada e fama pode dar esse
gato estamos votando errado era do é o
tchan eu sou eu estava assim o que nasce
torto nunca se direito que cada mãe na
casa e também um dia desse esse dia que
não é para o que nasce torto não cresce
direito é pau que nasce torto nunca sim
direita há pelo menos uma coisa tem a
ver com o outro é porque é um pau que
nasce torto não cresce direito mas
também um pau que nasce torto nunca se
em direito entendeu por que não eu nunca
nenhuma me falar pô meu pai o ator torce
pra esquerda marrey não há regras impor
a linha eram aí está um [ __ ] é a vender
um pouco o que é um direito ou nunca
tirei fica toda a vida inteira não errei
não serve como foco no core comigo não
tem isso pelo meio com verón não poderia
ser pior poderia ser pau que nasce torto
dormir ou cc e ayew 6 prima taesa eu
rezava erradas e ave maria cheia de
graça bendita sois vós entre as mulheres
em dita suas vozes entre as mulheres é o
reserva vida inteira assim o ano todo de
tão novo sério que meninas é casado e
gedo minerva mexer bastante com pessoas
nas américas o piso estiver vou falar
isso é verdade da mentira eu descobri um
dia desde que é bendita sois vós sempre
as mulheres ela quer bendita entre as
mulheres na voz dela quebra-quebra
também porque se ela é avó entendeu é
testando bendita sois hoya que vergonha
falar isso mas é verdade mas aqui também
cara tem uma coisa que eu não entrava
língua o negócio o povo inventa tava
língua porque chama trava língua porque
é para travar a língua porque fala coisa
que não é para ser falada que não existe
meu deus três pratos de treino para
treino e triste tigre é esse meu deus
que como trigo invenção na praceta trepa
de trigo até teve triste é por isso que
está triste
entrei no meu amigo eu só entreguei o
carro chega para mim comprar de treino
fico muito porque eu como é o cara que
levou o treino do flamengo no ninho de
mafra gava consigo uma faca foi o que
diabo é uma faca vamos ver o tema pagava
designe um dos personagens mais
tradicionais entre a trava línguas da
língua copa não inventar criar um
personagem de uma palavra difícil ele é
tá vendo é pois chama trava-língua pena
por falar no existem os 1.000 de marcar
gado fica uma garrafinha que é uma
garrafa utilizador vai comer o prato de
trigo do twitter este número cc e tanta
coisa que eu falava errado depois que eu
fazia errado dia 10 mesmo assim ele
estava com um amigo no posto manter veja
aí beleza não vão pagar aí eu fui pagar
com cartão e acaba de se não depois
desse horário que não paga mais que um
cartão só no dinheiro ele é um táxi
botei no gps banco24horas aí fungando
2014 ou a longe pra cá negócios 35
minutos mas tinha que pagar o negócio
estava no caixa 24 horas mais próximo e
pagar o dinheiro que foi o taxista
começam só por 15 claro que se ele não
for chegando no lugar era um banco 24
horas que ficava dentro de uma farmácia
que fechava a meia-noite a farmácia que
o desgraça não como é que eu ia reclamar
pq tá certo o banco estava ligado tava
tudo aceso dentro da farmácia que fechar
à meia-noite a farmácia toda apagada só
o banco24horas liga nova etapa é tentar
desligar a etapa 24 a farmácia no papel
podia ficar puto com ninguém nem com
caixa nem não foi maior porque tava
certo do ele comigo porque não tinha
ninguém rapel fui 2014 e de fato ele
estava a top está bem da forma a fechar
à meia-noite a forma esse caixa saiba
popular a ampliação da farmácia ele me
agrada é positiva dele sai pela teimas
já foi pra outra eu botei no gps já
olhei aproximei para vencer a dengue
alguma coisa e era um posto
eu já pensei que quando bem nesse posto
é de um cachorro aí eu cheguei lá ou de
novo porque o que eu fui sacar dinheiro
meu dinheiro nem que eu já tinha na
poupança e enquanto 24 horas não
tenhamos a cadeia de poupança outra
coisa que eu fazia errado deixar
dinheiro em poupança meu amigo dinheiro
em poupança não fará nada vai para o
daniel nildemar pagava trabalho do banco
é a tal da poupança que olha só quem
você só está rendendo no final de
escolha desculpe desculpe desculpe
desculpe otoni 1 após acordo antigamente
quando menino eu possa investir direito
eu já aprendi foi o primo rico e me
ensinou investir ele ensina investirá na
rico e pediu tanto tempo deixaria de
poupança não sei se um dia vou começar a
investir de 30 a 100 reais e já consegue
começar a investir no rio e como eu
disse eu me arrependo de ter deixado
dinheiro tanto tempo popó se é pra você
se cadastrar no rico tapas e começar a
investir de novo quanto mais cedo melhor
o encontro falando aproveitar novo para
o tempo passar e ele precisa trabalhar
mais o dinheiro ficar trabalhando por
você sozinho resumirá não conseguia
tirar o dinheiro e roubei tive que
voltar lá onde estava minha porque o
menino pago e liso só que o filme meus
amigos tinha que inventar a história por
causa do povo foi deixar eu passar a
noite de pagar e disposto a pagar
durante o dia e disse você morar aonde
aqui atrás na ogma pagava uma farofinha
interior meu amigo com sua confissão
souber quem é os pais é filho de quem eu
fi da dona chica nunes chicago não chega
de quem olha de quem dormir ou cerca
interior de goiás saber onde a mãe
trabalha porque se tudo pagar ele vai lá
e toma e trabalha para pedir o dinheiro
ela trabalha onde ela trabalha no ibama
protegendo os gatos da rua e extreme 3
se você gostou desse vídeo clique aqui e
gostaria que você comentasse aqui
embaixo que você cantava errado até hoje
o que se fazia de errado até hoje
além de deixar dia da poupança e não
abra uma conta na recra no canal para
não perder nenhum vídeo tamo junto à
rotunda junto não esquece o bebê é nóis
um beijo maravilhoso bem na minha você